how do you feel about people who say it
doesn't matter what you eat it just
matters how much and you should just be
looking at calories we have data now
from the nih there was that 2018 kevin
hall study that found that people on
ultra processed diets when invited to
consume ultra-processed foods add
libitum meaning to satiety all the food
that they wanted they ended up eating a
500 calorie per day surplus and if you
stretch that out over the course of the
week 500 calories a day that's a pound
of fat gain every week when they took
those same people and they gave them
minimally processed foods to consume
they ended up coming in at a calorie
deficit by about 300 calories so that's
an 800 calorie swing right there
determined purely by what you're eating
so what seems to be the case is that
what you eat determines at least to some
degree to a significant degree how much
you're eating basically if you're eating
unprocessed foods or less processed
foods you're less likely to overeat
absolutely you don't have to count the
calories you can just eat until you're
full and you're full faster with less
processed foods